china has the most extensive network
building and deploying the fifth
generation of cellular networks 5g runs
up to 100 times faster than 4g it has
built 1.6 million 5g base stations
across the country according to the
state-run people's daily in comparison
the u.s has about 100 000 yet instead of
trailing china the u.s could have been
the leader in 5g development had an
immigrant been allowed to stay in the
country erdo erican may not be a
household name yet he's so extraordinary
that chinese telecom giant huawei rolled
out the red carpet for him at its
headquarters in shenzhen in 2018. they
treated him like a rock star because he
developed the fundamental technology for
5g erican was born and raised in turkey
the son of a doctor and a stay-at-home
mom he loved science and studied
electrical engineering at middle east
technical university in ankara while in
his first year in 1977 erican's high
test scores allowed him to transfer to
the california institute of technology
known as caltech one of the world's top
universities with a strong focus on
science and engineering while there he
took a particular interest in
information theory a study of
mathematical laws that govern
communications including 5g networks
information theory was developed a few
decades earlier by the brilliant
mathematician claude shannon at att's
research arm bell labs his ideas laid
the groundwork for the digital
revolution he made the internet possible
in 1948 shannon published a mathematical
theory that showed how to transmit
messages accurately at the fastest speed
possible
say scott wants to send a message to
sarah a transmitter encodes information
into a signal which is corrupted by
noise and then decoded by the receiver
shannon's theory showed how to calculate
the maximum rate at which messages can
be set with zero errors to ensure that
the message scott sent is the same one
sarah received
according to shannon every
communications channel has a speed limit
for transmitting information reliably
referred to as the shannon limit however
shannon did not provide a technique for
constructing the code to achieve the
fastest rate possible or make it clear
how to compile such code that's where
erican came in after graduating from
caltech he took his interest in
shannon's theory to mit for his grad
studies his mentor there professor
robert gallagher was a renowned pioneer
in information theory who came close to
the shannon limit but never reached it
air khan would throw himself into this
work for the next 20 years trying to
attain what no one had yet been able to
do
after finishing his doctoral thesis in
1986 he briefly served as an assistant
professor at the university of illinois
at urbana-champaign however he was
reportedly unable to obtain a permanent
academic post in the u.s or funding to
continue his work on information theory
and as a foreign citizen he had to find
an american employer interested in
supporting him in order to remain in the
country but he failed to do so and had
no choice but to return to turkey
he once told wired the reason scientists
and engineers in the u.s don't spend
decades working on the same problem is
quote because they wouldn't be able to
get tenure they wouldn't be able to get
research funding
he returned to turkey to join the
country's first private non-profit
research institution bill kent
university now a leading institution in
the country he established its
engineering school and gave lectures in
published papers
but the shannon limit kept nagging at it
how do you transmit messages accurately
at the fastest possible speed
messages that you send letters and
emojis are converted into a string of
ones and zeroes called bits the problem
is noise can distort the message so
redundancies are required to make sure
the correct message is received
redundancies ensure that if an error
does creep in you can still be sure of
the correct string and what the original
message intended to say however there is
a trade-off the more redundancies you
add the slower the transmission rate so
how do you get around that problem after
working on it for over two decades
erican had a eureka moment in late 2005.
his solution was to make a copy of the
channel and transfer the noise from one
channel to the other so you're left with
one very noisy channel and the other
that's much cleaner the noise-free
channel could in theory reach the
shannon limit he dubbed his discovery
polar codes in reference to banishing
noise to the north pole so that there is
clear communication at the south pole he
continued to tinker with his discovery
and in 2009 he published his findings in
the field's top scientific journal to
much fanfare erikan tried to sell the
idea of polar codes to both qualcomm and
seagate but they declined no american
company was interested in his ideas he
blamed himself for not being a good
enough salesperson telling wired i was
an academic who did not know how to
promote an idea perhaps i did not
believe in the idea that strongly myself
but one company did believe in the idea
very strongly the head honchos at huawei
saw the potential of polar codes they
believed it was the breakthrough needed
to leap from 4g networks to 5g
polar codes are considered a direct
challenge to the american developed
coding method ldpc and are believed to
be superior to it the chinese company
bet big on polar codes investing
hundreds of millions of dollars to build
on arrogance work in fact when canadian
tech giant nortel went under huawei
poached its top researcher who grew up
in china winton would head huawei's r d
division on 5g huawei's engineers came
up with a software to make polar codes
work in practice and invented some of
the first 5g technologies huawei holds
the majority of polar code patents for
5g and has positioned itself as a world
leader in tech innovation
western countries insist huawei's
technology may intentionally contain
security holes that could be used by the
chinese government for spying which
huawei flatly denies the us has banned
its equipment
despite the tension between the east and
the west over the development of 5g
technology aircon is thankful that his
tireless work and refusal to give up has
finally paid off
as engineers
there is no greater reward
than seeing our ideas
turn into reality engineers like erica
are shaping the world of tomorrow if
you'd like to hone your stem skills so
you can build a product that can impact
a tremendous number of people brilliant
is a great way to brush up on your
science technology engineering and math
skills their courses are super
interactive i know my viewers love the
computer science fundamentals course
which helps strengthen your knowledge of
core computer science concepts and no
coding is required you can solve puzzles
with science through their scientific
thinking course start your algebra
journey with an introduction to
variables and equations or see fractions
percentages and ratios in everyday
contexts with their everyday math course
there's something for everyone no matter
your experience level whether you're a
student or you're working and want to
brush up on what you already know there
are no tests and if you ever get stuck
you can view the explanation for more
brilliant is free for you to try out if
you head to the custom link in my
description or pin comment brilliant.org
newsthink the first 200 people to click
my link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription which gives you
unlimited access to all of their
offerings thanks for watching for
newsthink i'm cindy palm
[Music]